[Music]
okay fantastic hey plastic pills
listeners i'm here uh today uh with a
very special guest actually uh this is
aaron and he is one of the founders of
the institute for christian socialism
and an editor of the bias magazine uh
for those of you who do not know uh ics
and the bias have made it their mission
to actually counteract some of the
right-wing interpretations of
christianity and provide a more vibrant
uh and altruistic uh conception of
the entity that's appropriate to the
left for the 21st century so thanks a
lot aaron for coming on we've been
wanting to have you here for a while
thanks for having me matt i wanted to
talk to you for a while so i really
appreciate the opportunity
perfect so i have a couple questions for
you but why don't we just start with the
most basic one uh what initially
inspired the creation of the institute
for christian socialism and the bias
magazine uh was it a personal event a
political transition some combination of
the two
and you just saw
some evangelical ad and that was the
last straw
[Laughter]
yeah plenty of evangelical ads to to
build some impetus for this project uh
and that continues to happen in fact no
um if i could put it very simply um
the institute for christian socialism uh
was formed
um out of a
profound frustration that many of us had
with the fact that there was no real
voice or organizing space
for christians who wanted to mount a
consistent
uh and sustained anti-capitalist
critique of society
um
and and in a sense that to do that um
one would need more than simply you know
a blog
uh even a standalone magazine
uh but that in order to uh sustain and
build a movement around that
uh we would need something like an
institute right an institute um
involves questions of people right
people power
uh
money
um
and the sort of network uh resources
organizing tools
that are necessary to actually build a
successful and long-lasting
uh christian anti-capitalist movement
um and so uh we we were um
launched in 2019 around just that
mission essentially to help um educate
and then organize christians
uh on the left right and and to say that
it's not to say that every single person
who encounters ics or gets involved is
themselves a committed leftist or
socialist many of them are
but kind of the the core concern and
anxiety many of them have is that
something is profoundly wrong with the
capitalist order and they want to fix
something about it and they would prefer
not to do that simply through moral
denunciations rights uh merely through
sectarian solutions through
the church
uh but they'd like to do something that
that affects long-lasting political
change um
and so that that's broadly how it came
together uh really out of a concern not
just to do something temporary
to make a small splash but in fact to
contribute to i think a landscape change
to fundamentally work towards retaking
the landscape of american politics and
and disrupting
um the monopolization of religion and
especially christianity by the
conservative uh you know neoconservative
and neoliberal rights
um and so in that sense where you know
you asked what this genesis was what
what the sparking event for it was i
think in many ways that you know ics is
not
um
ics owes itself to um
political energies and movements that
preceded it right i think it's safe to
say something like ics may not have
resonated or been as successful as it
has been
if we had launched even five years ago
but i think there's sufficient political
frustration anxiety
um around many uh you know uh recent
events in our past the great recession
uh the uh disastrous wars right um the
experiences of precarity
under neoliberal capitalism
and then most recently kind of the
bernie phenomenon right that there was a
real violent political voice um giving
expression to the concerns a lot of
young people have who are no longer
riding that wave
of you know the the beautiful you know
post-war capitalist boom
um and so you know there's a certain
energy that we're writing i think um and
now christians have i think much more
interest in getting politically
organized
um and mounting a real sustained
challenge to it um so that that's kind
of how it explain how it came about i
can certainly get more detail about like
the folks involved and then kind of how
our uh own personal histories led to ics
for sure well we'll definitely get into
that but just before we do uh you know
we're a left-wing podcast uh a lot of
our listeners uh are marxists uh or at
least a line uh frankly irreligious uh
or even anti-religious uh and you know
growing up i was raised roman catholic
uh so were a few of us i was very devout
when i was younger but one of the
reasons i
it was apost most of the roman catholics
i knew were pretty
big c conservative
and almost all the catholics i met who
were big are religious were big c
conservative and at some point i just
said you know i had enough and i can't
deal with it any longer so can you tell
us a little bit about what the reception
of ics has been uh because honestly just
looking back in my own kind of history i
would have really liked something like
this uh when i was
growing up it would have been really
refreshing uh
kinda wish it was there in hindsight but
you know that's the way things go so how
christians responded to this generally
that's a great question
um i i share with you matt this feeling
that um
had there been something like the
institute for christian socialism our
relationship to our faith and our
religious past may have been very
different
uh because some people all say you know
simply ics saved my faith that's kind of
simplistic and that that kind of looks
over the fact that you know faith for me
is an ongoing struggle every single day
and there are many incentives many days
uh to to just look at the whole project
of christianity its relation to politics
and say it's just not worth it but that
said i think ics for me has been
very integral in in
restoring my faith in a kind of
politically radical uh socialist
christianity or at least the possibility
of that
um so i agree with you there i mean
you're right one of the biggest and
hardest questions for us to answer both
as we launch ics and then as we uh you
know are engaged in the daily work right
of
uh publishing and and speaking and
intervening
uh who is our audience right one of the
difficulties of ics is that um
in creating the institute you both have
to respond to an audience and create an
audience at the same time right
so so you know to get back to some of
the earlier personal stories you know a
lot of us had real concerns and
critiques of our experience of academic
spaces and church spaces
where there were nominal commitments and
and oftentimes very pronounced
commitments in the pulpits and in the
classrooms to social justice to
progressive values
but very little material investment of
those things right very little material
analysis of those things and certainly
no willingness to actually criticize
capitalism
um in a forthright way
um and so a lot of a lot of the genesis
of ics again was out of this frustration
so there's a small audience in the sense
of those people who were involved in ics
at the start wanted to say
there's nothing out there for people
like us who feel so frustrated with this
reality we want to do something about it
so you know our our first audience was
ourselves right trying to collaborate
and think about um how do we make the
sort of developing commitments and
critiques that we have public and draw
people in but then we realized once we
launched ics that there were a lot of
people out there
and especially i would say not even
people who would immediately identify as
christian leftists or socialists but
rather people who had been profoundly
burned out by the church or abused by
the church or traumatized by other
christians
um and so certainly you know social
media is uh no perfect indicator of who
your audience is
but in the last two and a half years
since we've launched it's quite clear to
us that like the people who are
attracted to us and engage with the
social media reach out to us directly
are very often people who have had um
negative uh racialized experiences of
being a christian right queer and trans
folk uh people who've been kicked out of
their family's home right for heterodoxy
rights or things like that um so people
who have been profoundly alienated um
and are by no means um closed off to the
idea of christianity but to them it's
basically become something that they
practice individually and they really
can't find any kind of materialization
of their own sense of the radical jesus
rights and the right kind of radical
christianity that they might espouse
um
and so i think it's a lot of people who
are just looking for for an institution
or organization
that really is willing to make good on
these claims of a radical jesus
um
i think one of the other harder things
is like
it is difficult in our current climate
to make any kind of like strong
political claims about christianity just
because it has been so co-opted by the
right i think a lot of people are very
afraid
christians i should say are very afraid
to claim the banner of socialism um
precisely because any sorts of bold
radical claims
run the risk right of playing into the
hands of rightman christianity right and
so this is one of the ways that you know
what mark fisher describes as capitalist
realism has taken such a strong hold in
america
um
it seems better to kind of couch one's
critique of capital and injustice by you
know um kind of organizing around uh
banners like progressivism right
radicalism anarchism things like that
um but but there are real risks i think
to take it on the socialist banner i
mean among many uh it's hard to get
funding for institute if you're calling
yourself a socialist right um it's hard
to develop strong associations with
certain folks that might be privately
inclined to support you um but you know
so that's certainly um you know a a big
risk that goes along with it um i think
you know um
one of the other difficulties is trying
to help people locate where is this
christian socialist tradition right
um i think a lot of people who have come
to engage ics
um
again have this experience of being
profoundly alone the the sense that
there must be no one who thinks like me
no one who's come before me
um and so where do i go right so so part
of our task has been to try to
reconstruct what we call kind of the
christian socialist tradition or the
socialism of the gospel as we've dubbed
it um to look to those figures who have
practiced uh radical economic political
and social justice those who have always
stood sometimes within the church but
very much outside of it to critique it
from the outside
uh and call it to the the virtues of
justice and mercy in a political way
um
and you know
one of the things we have to to do to
successfully organize christians is
uh remain strongly ecumenical so ics is
not um
an organization that demands adherence
to one denomination or any denomination
right
and we also have to maintain a kind of
ecumenical approach to the secular left
right so there's these kind of like
constant temptations i think with
christians who want to
appear radical or anti-capitalist and
really double down on their own
theological tradition to do that um or
and or to avoid the contributions and
the critiques and the education that the
secular left uh can provide right and so
it's having to kind of like thread that
needle right constantly remaining
ecumenical both theologically
uh and politically is super important
that is the only way that we can
actually build power though i think is a
successful christian anti-capitalist
institute
yeah i know i absolutely agree with you
especially given the hegemony of the
american right not just in the united
states uh but in terms of the influences
had on conservatism generally there
needs to be a counter push for
christians in other religious types uh
who feel differently uh but
i'm the kind of challenge as i see it
and this is a more conceptual question
uh especially when trying to make
christianity appealing to leftists is
that since at least the 18th century
many many different um conservatives
with reactionary dispositions even
virulently reactionary dispositions have
tended to argue for
everything from throne and altar style
conservatism with joseph de mestra right
down through the evangelical right with
its associations uh with trumpism and
the republican party
and the belief that you know the gospel
tells us that we should work be thrifty
uh put our pennies aside and if you do
well then god will reward you in this
life these things have been tremendously
influential so i imagine at some point
it has to feel a bit like scaling a
mountain uh
to try to actually make the case for
christian socialism can you talk a
little bit about how your interpretation
of the christian message is different
and why you think it will resonate uh
beyond just the fact that of course you
think it's the correct interpretation of
the christian myth right right
that's a really great question matt um
yeah i can take a stab at that so
actually i think the first place that i
would start
is by honestly admitting actually that
the dominant forms of christianity
across the globe uh have often been
overwhelmingly reactionary
uh and not just christianity in the
modern era though you're certainly right
to point out that there there's a kind
of fusion that happens in the modern era
that brings them into very close
alliance with reactionary thought um
you know the the entire project of
european christianity i would say is
responsible for an outrageous legacy of
violence and colonialism and slavery
and one that has profound effects even
today
so in other words um i think we need to
avoid this this kind of common and
understandable clap back that you find
sometimes in progressive christian
circles
um and it's one that conservative
christians engage in too where it's like
well sure you know a lot of christians
have done terrible things but that
wasn't true christianity or they weren't
real christians
um but but the fact is that some of the
most grievous evils of the last two
millennia have been committed by
practicing christians and the church uh
and people who profess christian
orthodoxy too right they held very
strong views uh theological views on
human sin and failure and they use those
very doctrines uh to engage in products
of violence and domination and class
oppression and they develop very you
know sophisticated rationales for this
violence using the resources of theology
and and christianized philosophy
um you can look at recent works uh like
like that done by willie james jennings
on race right uh his thesis is that like
racial formation didn't have its origins
just in colonialism but also had a
theological beginning that fused it to
the western colonial project
you can pick really any systemic
world making evil over the last two
millennia and you'll find christianity
lurking there somewhere you know racism
uh slavery um anti-semitism
violence against lgbtq people women and
it's not even lurking there in many
cases it's explicitly providing the very
frameworks and rationales that
legitimate the domination of these
people
um
i think one theologian i would point
people to of your podcast that's really
important on this front is marika rose
uh she has this great book it's it's
fairly complex academically but but it's
it's important and and other folks like
um
dean and matt at the magnificast podcast
that have spoken with her about this
idea of christianity is a kind of
ongoing failure and and a need to
grapple with that failure
but christianity she says has always
struggled with and fought against
supremacist theology since its very
inception
um
and and sort of every new theological
current is trying to find a way out of
these impasses right trying to assume
some normative standard pristine
christianity
but i think honestly i would say matt
one of the most important starting
points is that christian leftists if
they want to be honest about this legacy
have to actually acknowledge the damage
and wreckage of christianity we have to
acknowledge that there is failure there
um but there's more that you can say i
think i mean ics obviously exists and we
think that there's something important
and vital about christianity um in the
radical life of jesus the kind of
political love he embodied
um and the love that has been extended
by many of his followers
and the contribution i think that that
kind of political love can make to the
left
um
one thing i would point to is actually a
book that the
members who are part of ics's membership
program are currently reading
by obri hendrix it's called the politics
of jesus
and and obri's book is profound because
what it does is basically make the case
that um
in both jewish and christian scripture
the the point at which god makes his
most explosive entrance onto history
right
uh which is his intervention in the
oppression
of the hebrews under uh pharaoh
is basically a political intervention
right so this is not just some god who
responds to the piety rights
of the israelites but instead the very
reason god appears and intervenes
is to free
uh these people from their political
plight as an oppressed social class
and in fact israel
as a people often in the hebrew
scriptures constantly
refuses uh a god right uh and god
continues to intervene to free them not
just from some vague spiritual bondage
right but from actual oppressors
and even as the life of liberty and
israel develops after the exodus their
whole system of uh political rule is set
up around a system that resists monarchs
and hereditary rulers
and as that goes on in the life of jesus
that is the very context in which jesus
um uh begins his own ministry right uh
the hebrew people are now on a press
colonial subject under rome
and jesus experience would have been
that of you know uh his his parents
walking the roads of rome seeing jews
crucified on the road on the crosses for
rebelling
it would have been one in which he was
he was opposed to an aristocratic
hereditary case basically a priest who
would acquiesce to rome's rule and
oppress their own people
his challenge was directly to this
religious political order that had
refused god's sovereignty right the one
god that israel worships
and a resistance to the use of wealth
and power and privilege
that were used to lay these heavy
burdens on the jewish people in other
words i think the very first thing one
has to look at is the fact that jesus's
life was thoroughly political he grew up
in a thoroughly politicized context and
all of his interventions right as a
teacher as a minister as a kind of
political rattle radical took place in a
very specific
political and social structure of
violence and oppression
um
you know uh the liberation theologian
gustavo gutierrez
talks about this this this pr very
pervasive um idea of jesus that is is i
would say no more pronounced than it is
in america right especially in the kind
of evangelical uh portrayal of jesus and
spirituality you know jesus becomes kind
of just a script he says he's deprived
of any historical human content he's
there just saying things that are really
just recitations of other theological
truths there's no real body yeah i mean
he's kind of defanged is the impression
you get from the book that's right
that's exactly right
um but it's really hard once you kind of
take pause
and imagine and reconstruct jesus's own
context right that jesus is not
you know um some kind of um you know
easygoing wisdom teacher he's not
confrontational right in some general
way he's not just curmudgeonly he's not
someone who enjoys exposing people's
individual sins like my evangelical
ancestors told me
his confrontations his interventions and
his struggles were always focused and
specific
against the rich
against the roman imperial order and
those who acquiesced to it and they were
always interventions on behalf of the
vulnerable and the excluded and the
outcasts
and so i think it's super important as
gutierrez says to realize that like the
kind of love that jesus announces
and that he experiences from his father
it's not some kind of abstraction right
it's not some kind of sentimental truth
that preserves i think what gutierrez
calls it fictitious harmony right it's a
love that calls people into solidarity
with the oppressed so this is a kind of
love that actually calls you into forces
you into the process of liberation
and the wages that goes about this is
his universal love means that he sides
with the oppressed
and his struggle against oppressors is
not motivated out of a hatred right or
ambition
in fact the act of freeing oppressors
from their power to oppress is itself an
act of love the kind that jesus calls us
to
so i think it's really important to say
that like the example and the life of
jesus show us that like
he is not an abstraction
um in fact the the center focus of
christianity that person of jesus christ
is thoroughly political
um and he calls us to a form of love
that is thoroughly engaged thoroughly
material has profound social and
material implications and it's it's it's
a kind of love that he calls us to that
is very
um insistent
that we must free those oppressed and to
free those who are oppressing is also a
kind of political love if that makes
sense
um
there are all kinds of you know
structures of theology readings of
scripture
uh for you know formations of church
denominations and and the power that
they seek to form with other political
parties that certainly militate against
this reading this radical reading of
jesus but i think it's just um
impossible to ignore once you have a
holistic view about the hebrew and
christian scriptures that that is the
whole context of god's intervention
especially in the person of jesus christ
that he's committed from from the
beginning and even to the cross to
justice and he dies at the hands of
political oppressors right jesus doesn't
go to the cross and die there because of
some vague you know sentimental message
about love he doesn't go there
necessarily because because of his
teaching but he goes there because of
certain life that teaching them that
life is ordered towards freedom of the
oppressed
um and it's such a political death that
he that he goes to the cross
committed to this radical liberative
love
um
and i think that's the kind of message
that that radical leftist christians are
clinging to
um does that make sense
yeah it absolutely makes sense and i
mean i think the point that you made
initially
which is that there are many different
ways of interpreting the gospel
including right-wing ways
and people need to own the legacy of
that is extremely important you know
it's worth noting that john c calhoun
the vice president of the united states
staunch defender of the south often
appeal to not just religious imagery but
religious arguments and examples in the
bible to support the institution of
slavery uh on the other hand of course
we have mlk uh and the various leaders
of the civil rights movement often
emerging and it kind of see over their
baptist tradition that mobilize the
resources imagery and spirituality of
the bible to stand against racism and
tyranny and oppression right so there's
this constant battle i would say
in trying to save the emancipatory
message of the gospels from the
temptations of sovereignism uh and this
kind of
calcification or fetishization of power
speaking of which uh at the moment
there's obviously a very strong
christian right in the united states
somebody even is a kind of burgeoning or
aggressive christian right
and his leading intellectual edge is
often perceived to be the so-called
post-liberal movement now this is
complicated and some of our listeners
might know about this but broadly
speaking post-liberals tend to emerge
out of a right-wing christian
typically catholic kind of environment
and they argue that even the kind of
capitalist-friendly liberalism that we
see in the united states right now isn't
going far enough uh that we want the
united states to emulate a country more
like poland or hungary um you know with
their kind of quasi-authoritarian
governments their strong restrictions on
immigration technology immigration from
islamic countries and the enforcement of
a very socially conservative uh kind of
outlook can you tell us why you think
post-liberalism
appeals to so many on the christian
political right and how can a christian
left confront it intellectually since of
course that's what we're trying to do
here on this podcast amongst other
things yeah that's right that's right
well i could just be really lazy about
and just say like uh rather than listen
to me just read anything that you or sam
adler bell or matt sitman had to say
about these things
yeah i've had a few i've taken a few
shots at them that's for sure but
so i think there are
a lot of things we could say here um
obviously the phenomenon of
post-liberalism which as you say is is
overwhelmingly kind of a catholic
anti-liberalism um
is emergent it's constantly changing
um it's a project certainly on the move
um
but i think one thing i've noted about
it is that
you know it it partakes of um
a
common strain of conservative
catholicism
uh which is that it's a reaction to the
kind of trauma of secularism and
modernity um the loss of religious
consensus the loss of strong authority
a sort of um solid place in the world
but you know as freud would say trauma
is usually unspoken right it's repressed
so it rears its head in morbid and
unrecognized ways and i think that
certainly this this catholic post
liberalism is a kind of morbid symptom
of capitalism exactly how we can talk
about that um first i think it's
important to say it often goes unnoticed
although you have certainly uh
pinpointed this in your pieces on the
catholic post liberals but it goes
unnoticed i think just how reliant
post-liberalism
is on liberalism and modernity and
absolutely yeah i mean there's almost a
parasitic relationship in the sense that
post liberals define themselves so
strenuously uh by basically saying uh
like the arctic monkeys once did you
know whatever it is that they are we're
not yes that's right that's right
um and and again you know i would say
the post liberals aren't stupid in this
respect right although they do seem to
be you know unable to stop saying stupid
things on social media that's true but
at the same time i i don't know about
you but i find a sort of like mendacity
a sort of willful ignorance
about just how shaky their whole project
is like on intellectual and theological
grounds right and i think you grasped
that
um
so i think it's important to kind of
mine these vulnerabilities and these
contradictions i think one of the
reasons
that it can seem so mendacious and
willfully ignorant is that it is first
and foremost a movement of reaction like
in the sense that corey robin talks
about right in this book the reactionary
mind
that is it's a movement of largely elite
academics theologians and
i guess you could say wonks right that
are fundamentally animated
by a desire to repopularize private
power in the face of the volatility of
capitalism
i think one of the clearest examples of
the way this this comes up is the way
that post liberals oddly talk about the
elite layers of politics and culture
right trying to portray
themselves
um and a figure like for instance donald
trump right as as outspi outsiders
speaking for a you know quiet majority
of kind of white working-class folks
traditional folks
um against like these elite layers of
media and politics and hollywood and the
university and things like that which is
just a wildly um
i think incorrect analysis of the way
things actually work in america though
certainly it does leverage some
you could say
some vulnerable points of liberalism
right it's i think inarguable that there
are profound problems with the captivity
of these let's call them elite layers of
politics and culture because of
capitalism right
um but but to make these claims right
that that that in fact the post liberals
are speaking from the outside right as
part of this real majority of america
right that's attempting to retake the
totalitarian takeover of like woke elite
technocrats right everywhere
i think this is very very silly um now
that that said um i do think we should
take notice of how close some of this
rhetoric is to strands of christian
anti-capitalism and i would also kind of
almost put that in air quotes more like
christian critiques of like consumerism
right rights and longs i think that's
absolutely right i mean
one of the problems of course they're
not necessarily structurally uh opposed
to capitalism uh they're opposed to
excessive liberal permissiveness right
and to the extent consumer culture maps
on to that they might be critical of
some market outcomes and say the stakes
who could strain them uh but they're not
really not in favor of confronting the
power of capital in any sustained way uh
transforming social relations by moving
to a different economic system none of
that is
of much interest to them let's just put
it that way that's right uh this is
something that you targeted really well
matt in your piece on paul tillich's uh
little known book or at least too little
known uh book the socialist decision
right um there was a discussion there
what exactly
uh the relationship is of capitalism to
freedom right and i think one of the
things that that really sets the post
liberals apart
and and puts them uncomfortably close i
think to a lot of christians that
espouse a kind of third way
anti-capitalism right it could be in the
forms of like distributism
um corporatism things like that um the
real concern is rooted in anxieties
about liberalism not capitalism per se
right and so when it comes to the
question of freedom which is something
liberalism offers right in a kind of
radical way at least at the level of
ideas
uh the problem for post-liberals is not
that capitalism makes us too unfree
right that's the leftist critique but
the capitalism certainly creates
conditions for freedom but it
systemically blocks them rights under
the rule of capital uh the problem for
post liberals is that capitalism has
actually made us too free right
and so um
this this is really rooted in its
anxiety its resentment towards
liberalism i think that's where the real
object of critique is and so as you
rightly pointed out they're perfectly
happy to make certain kind of critiques
of capitalism though they rarely use
that term itself but they might critique
corporations right the domination of
corporations
um
they may engage in a little bit of
um
uh you know
sort of critique of the lack of labor
unions rights
um they may valorize that the needs of
workers even use terms like the working
class
um but in the end sarah barmara has been
on a tear that way
yes and for this reason this is why i
say mother bell is right i think to call
them like the labor curious
post-liberals right they have a certain
curiosity about uh the the working
laboring classes and and they're willing
to even engage in some rhetoric about
supporting those classes but in their
minds what they're harkening back to is
not the working class as it actually
exists right
uh they're they're harkening back to
working class that in their minds was
solidly centered in you know male
breadwinning families in the manure
manufacturing industries rights and so
what they're seeking again is not so
much the dignity of labor right strong
working-class rights uh union power what
they want to do is advocate for labor in
so far as it represents right a kind of
older
male
white working class and and this is
where i think post liberalism becomes
actually as we both can probably agree
dangerous in some ways right
it's participating in certain far-right
discourses right about what's wrong with
america and has shown itself to be quite
happy to cozy up with authoritarian
leaders politicians not just in america
but across the world
um
so i think you know um
again what we're dealing with here and
what left us have to be super clear
about especially christian leftists
because again you've pointed this out
matt in your writing um we have to make
a careful nuanced case
in support of the emancipatory
dimensions of liberalism as
anti-capitalists right we cannot make
the reactionary move of trying to get
behind liberalism which is exactly what
post-liberals try to do is to chuck it
even though they may be secretly reliant
on it in ways they're not willing to
admit right
or foreground um but you know uh as as
matt sitman i believe has said before
you know for socialists we want to go
directly through liberalism and
radicalize it right we want to make it
make it good on its promises
post liberals want to get behind it
right in order to regress or at least to
forcibly introduce um you know a more
homogeneous um social order right that
excludes what they see
as um you know depraved and licentious
forms of like sexual life rights and
um you know that the problem of like you
know transgender bathrooms things like
that right
their critique is solidly focused on
that yeah i mean this is one of the
things uh sam adler amongst others
pointed out that if you skim through uh
any number of their text yeah every now
and then as you put it you'll find some
labor light
or working-class light kind of curiosity
well they'll say a nice thing about
unions and say some bad things about
tech companies but if you add up all the
words that they'll write talking about
why it is that we should reconfigure the
relationship between capitalists and the
working class and you compare that to
all the worlds they'll fixate on
transgender bathrooms uh there's really
no comparing the two right uh throwing
the stuff about you know them being
opposed to the so-called gay agenda uh
and
it's just you know mountains next to
molehills and that really should give
you a sense of what it is that they're
prioritizing in my opinion that's right
matt yeah i think that's right and and
just the last thing i would say here
maybe is is
again i want to point out that
there's there is a certain intelligence
to post liberalism in the sense that
like other right-wing populist
discourses and far-right discourses and
movements it's able to kind of cynically
leverage the failures of liberalism like
there are real gaping failures of
liberalism insofar as it supports and
protects the interests of capital right
it has real failures to realize its own
promises right um
post-liberalized post-liberals will um
step in and say feminism itself is the
problem right redressing racial
inequality itself is the problem
transgenderism as they call it
derogatively is out of control and we're
at the brink of the destruction the
nuclear family and all these things and
these are very silly silly things right
but but they are
um
they are zeroing in on something that's
very important right the fact that
capitalism constrains and configures
liberalism right so you know for
instance uh
you know many um
households with a woman and a man right
that are that are at the head of the
household are still profoundly unequal
in terms of wages and access to the
workplace and family care and things
like that
um you know the the disparities of race
across almost all lines are still very
pronounced if not more than they were
during the civil rights era
um transgender folks are still widely
oppressed right violence is committed
against them at outrageous rates and so
these are silly claims to make but but
you know there's a sense in which um
liberalism has valorized like the
abstract you know causes of feminism
racial equality uh queer liberation
right but it's not able to actually make
material good on those things right and
so
post liberals step into that gap and say
no no the whole problem is
feminists and racial justices and things
like that what we want to say of course
is that we've barely achieved the kind
of substantive progress we need around
those things right it's not enough to
just acclaim them
and put them you know uh in like you
know um but you know it's not enough to
simply claim them in the classroom uh
it's not enough to simply um you know uh
announce that you're on indigenous land
right these things have to be made
materially
um present right uh actual justice has
to be achieved here and very often
liberalism itself
under the rule of capital is unable to
do these things
yeah no i think that's absolutely right
uh and in many senses i've seen a lot of
my own projects uh as being saving
liberalism from capitalism or at least
was best in liberalism from capitalism
i mean obviously there are some people
who are reticent to embrace that project
but i think it can be achievable
maybe i'm wrong who knows but i mean
that actually is a good segue to my last
kind of big picture question uh which is
i think that most of our listeners will
think that's an admirable project
definitely there's a need for a kind of
christian left to counteract the
influence of the christian right whether
it's post-liberalism or otherwise uh but
there'll definitely be at least a few
people who are skeptical the whole way
down uh and you can think about this
classical marxist critique which holds
that religion is
an ideological opiate for the masses um
and you know the heart of a heartless
world as he puts it
and the argument made by people who
really internalize at least a kind of
crude version of this critique is that
religion will only ever reinforce a kind
of ideological complacency in the face
of oppression at best
or will
help people graduate towards reactionary
movements at worst so how can you
convince them uh that there is something
of value to a radical revolutionary
movement
and it's sustainable in the face of the
kind of immense pressures that many
religious people and others uh face
under neoliberalism
great question
uh i can't i can't claim to convince any
of your listeners have a very long
conversation
it it you know it's it's you're right
that it's a long standing
convert our listeners right yeah yeah
right right um it's a long-standing line
of criticism it's one that in fact has i
think a lot of power um and so i think
you'd find among a lot of people that
work in ics
or our collaborators with us some basic
appreciation for marx and indeed you'd
find many marxists among us
um and i count myself as a kind of
marxist
um you know
i think one thing to say is that
certainly the the whole um
image of opiate has often been
misunderstood right um
marx didn't have a lot of sympathy for
religion certainly not christianity um
but you know he was an absolute
solidarity with a proletariat right and
so his analysis of the world religion
um
for the proletariat is you know far more
nuanced than say the kind of reactionary
criticisms of like richard dawkins or
daniel uh absolutely i mean again i
foregrounded the heart of a heartless
world part of that quote for that reason
right uh in the sense that he's not
saying this is just an opiate uh
in a context where people are exploited
and have very little to live for this
can provide a tremendous sense of
meaning uh for them and it's not to be
taken lightly is the sense in which i
read his text yep yep that's right
that's right
um yeah precisely right and and this is
also why you know he he writes uh later
that you know that religious suffering
is an expression of of real suffering
right so he he calls on people
um or at least says you know basically
calling people to give up their
illusions
about their actual condition
uh is to call on them to give up the
condition that requires illusions right
what marx is engaged here
in here i think is ideology critique
right he's interested in the way that
religion um helps to rationalize
and to justify the way that the social
order works and i would say marx in the
way he describes much of religion and
the germany that he inhabits is you know
98 spot on i have to say
um
but i think yeah i think we need to ask
um
you know whether marx is engaged here in
a critique of what christians would call
god
or whether he's engaged here in a
critique of an idol right
um and i think many christians would
happily agree
uh that um you know for one atheism is
an essential
dialogue partner for christians um it's
important i think that we learn to
radicalize our notion of god by getting
rid of idols that especially idols that
help to portray god in a way that um
justifies the status quo right very
often conceptions of god
go right along with the conception of
social order justice revolution things
like that what's possible and impossible
right in the order i mean absolutely i
mean just to segue on that uh terry
eagleton wrote a very good book where i
pointed out that in many ways uh marx's
critique of commodity fetishism joins a
long history uh of christian and jewish
critiques of idolatry right uh and the
way that that can
be
a tool uh to reinforce different power
dynamics that's right
i mean christians have a name for this
god as do many other monotheists and
that name is mammon
right um and actually yes that's right
commodity fetishism is something that
marx he employs somewhat religious terms
to actually talk about that um there's
also the category of what marx calls
abstract value right and and so like the
commodity and the abstract value
certainly function as a kind of of of
god right it kind of kind of mystified
god that gives order to the universe um
and especially in the workplace right
um
but yeah i think i think for christians
we have a very different idea of who god
is right that that one is again drawn
from the hebrew scriptures and the
gospel
um the dominican friar herbert mccabe
you know talks about how the greatest
insight of the hebrew people was
realizing that god
um is not a god
right uh and that that that he is not a
fundamental justification for an
oppressive social order
the social order the old testament was
rooted in the emancipation of slaves
right from pharaoh's political economy
and christians say that we come to know
who god is from what happens to him
under colonial roman powers when they
torture him and murder him right um so i
think it's it's really important to to
highlight here that
um there is a god of capitalism there is
a god of slaveholder religion there is a
god of nationalism but it's certainly
for christians not the god of jesus
right
um and and and so yeah i i think there's
there's a lot more dialogue here to be
done i mean one of the things that we're
trying to do at the bias in the ics is
to actually revive older conversations
among people who might identify as are
you know orthodox marxists uh communists
uh there was there was a a huge
explosion of conversation in the
dialogue both in america
and across the world um you know uh
during the the global communist
revolutions that put christianity and
communism and marxism and conversation
in a very productive way and i think the
fact that kind of the new atheism has
sucked all the air out of the room right
and in some cases actually given i think
non-religious or atheist marxist a
little too much fodder to fight
religious folks i think the na the
nature and the state of that
conversation is very impoverished i also
think we should point out too that that
um
globally speaking especially the global
south right um it just is a non-starter
i think to say that religion can't play
an important part right in the
radicalization of people's politics and
in some sense it's a very abstract
critique because
uh people derive immense uh energy i
think an inspiration for socialist and
radical and progressive causes all over
the world ics is one of those examples
we're trying to contribute to that and
revive it
um so i i think also on material grounds
given that like the state of uh
christianity and politics across the
globe it's kind of a non-starter for
anybody who wants to build a real global
leptus movement i think
yeah absolutely and i mean uh for those
of our listeners who are interested um
of course looking at the liberation
theology tradition uh particularly
coming out of latin america would be a
very important place i think we're
starting to learn about how some of
these dialogues can be productively uh
engaged in
or you can take a look at paul tillich's
the socialist decision uh which i think
is one of the best books written in a
protestant context on the subject so
listen uh aaron i really appreciate that
you coming on i just have one last
question for you which is what do you
think is next for ics and the bias where
do you see yourself as going what would
you hope to do in a couple of years uh
and
is there anything interesting uh that'll
be coming out in the near future yeah i
sure hope so yeah i can speak to that um
the um
most important development for ics uh is
the launch of our membership program so
in october we launched a
membership program that um
sort of uh
is modeled around many different
grassroots experiments
um over the last decades and even
hundreds of years where christians have
gathered and organized at the grassroots
in spiritual and political communities
to affect to affect change and practice
forms of economic democracy
um and so what we're doing is gathering
people as members into what we call
based societies this does actually
harken back to the earlier latin
american based communities and we're
putting people into small groups that
are organized around a training
curriculum spiritual exercises and
organizing practices and this is to make
good on our mission which is to organize
christians right not just to
ask them to find other people to
advocate for them or to mobilize around
short-term causes but to actually build
a grassroots movement over time that we
hope
in the next couple of years will be in
the thousands
um and um so i would encourage people
who are interested in getting to know
other christian socialists
and who want to actually form community
christian anti-capitalist community to
check that out
that's easily
found at our website on the membership
page
that's where we're looking to actually
grow a movement mat so that's the most
important thing and the most exciting
thing in the last year
also we're developing more media so
we'll have a number of new podcasts
coming out of ics
um and the bias is actually launched in
a few series um this year uh one will
look at figures the christian left so
resourcing people that may be a little
less known
on the christian left uh and doing
profiles of them so people can get to
know what this christian socialist
tradition is locate themselves in it and
then um
be inspired by their examples
um we're also going to be um uh engaging
in a couple of long analyses of how
christians are currently engaging in
anti-capitalist politics especially with
a lot of focus on some of the
insufficient ways they're doing that
and then we're also working in a project
to republish older and lesser known
works from the christian left over the
past hundred years there's a lot of
little known material that's uh you know
out of copyrights just waiting to be
republished and represented to the
public so we're planning to use the bias
as a space for that
um
otherwise i would say people should
definitely check out our website
christiansocialism.com
uh we really want people to join us in
this crucial work it doesn't happen
without people and we're trying to build
a responsive institution that actually
we can
give others access to right we talk a
lot about ics exists for the people that
are involved in it in some sense it's
really theirs
and we want to be able to equip them and
resource them and organize them to start
affecting change in their churches and
communities so christiansocialism.com is
where we're at if you're interested in
supporting us there's also a support
page there you can subscribe to our
newsletter and we're also on twitter
facebook and instagram okay well thanks
a lot uh so that's aaron anderson
everyone uh do check out uh
the ics website and the bias magazine uh
as aaron mentioned i've been known to uh
have a piece come out there every now
and then as well uh so if you're
interested in that you can check it out
uh but you know thanks a lot for coming
here man and i
hope for the best uh
in the your organization's future
because i really think this is an
extremely important mission uh if
anything it's probably more vital now
than it has been in many many decades
given how nasty uh some of these
right-wing christians happen to be
awesome man i really enjoy the
conversation thanks for having me on
[Music]
you